[Applause]
how do they avoid
the fake shamans that's the truth you
know
i mean that's what are the things that
they can look for etcetera because that
that is a concern of mine if they
listen to this and then they go after it
and then they end up in the hands of
some [ __ ] douchebag in tulum
yeah that's the problem there's no real
shamans in tulum
so don't do it until don't do ayahuasca
in tulum there's ayahuasca is not
natural in tulum
it's it's not there's not a there's no
way you know people say oh my shaman's
been
learned in with the shamans in tulum but
the tulum is peyote
like peyote like grandfather medicines
you know not ayahuasca it also comes
from the rain forest right so the thing
is the tricky part like
i can't name someone who was serving
medicine five years ago in america
that because they ayahuasca you know
what happens is they start trying to
cheat the system right
so like okay i'm not going to drink it
they tell me oh i've just drink enough
ayahuasca i'm already connected
so then they don't drink the medicine
they servitalize people i was like oh
really
and now you don't know what's going to
happen so they they they like all of a
sudden like ah
and they you know and so then if someone
has a really bad experience
anyone else who's in that room is never
going to drink medicine with that person
again and tell everyone not to
so by default karma fixes that
how are you going to be a shaman with no
no one to serve
it's like being a chef when no one wants
to eat your food yeah yeah right pick
something else
okay and so i say trust your intuition
how long has someone been doing it
but a lot of people you know there are
good mechanics and there are bad
mechanics there's bad mechanics been
mechanic for 26 years
right you know so it's really [ __ ]
tricky man so in other words like
make sure they're highly recommended by
somebody that you know and trust and
it's had that experience
that's the most important thing don't
worry about you know anyone who's
promoting like
you know like my like instagram says i'm
an iowa schedule because i am an
ayahuasca
but i'm not like putting posts on my
story like ceremony in los
angeles you know like that watch out for
that
you know for me 100 i would say 99.
ninety-nine percent of the people i
serve medicine to are coming because
someone they know
was like you gotta do it with him yeah
that's that's the goal
i've served medicine to over eight
thousand people man yeah
you know uh and there's never been a
there's never been a promotional
uh post with it ayahuasca my job
as an ayahuasca is to plant seed and to
build bridges
my job is not to serve ayahuasca to the
whole world it's impossible
you know so if i plant the seed like you
had the seed planted by someone
sometimes
thank you emily so much for making this
happen emily at ampersand studios
and uh yeah you were very sweet to make
this connection and
thank you for uh yeah thank you guys
here man thank you yeah i mean i've been
watching your stuff for a while i saw
you in respect
rogan and respect monologues are the
goat
the monologues i didn't realize that was
part of a netflix special i was catching
those monologues i was like thank god
someone's
yeah yeah dropping it but you can you
can say because you're you're a comedian
right exactly shaman they they go how
dare you
how dare you have a belief how dare you
how dare you not agree with everything
the narrative but um the yeah man it's
just it's just tricky you have to
like word of mouth someone you know
number one
but at the end of the day is preparation
and intention like
good reasons to you know to experience
the medicine but at the end of the day i
can tell you one thing for sure without
that i've never ever heard anyone ever
tell me
ever that they wish they didn't do it i
don't care if you have stage five
pancreatic cancer
and you were literally purging for three
and a half hours
i don't care if if you're coming with
the only intention of healing
child molestation right i don't care if
you
thought you were a really good person
that's the best the people that think
they're really good people
and then ayahuasca is like really you
because they're so delusional
that they think they're really good but
they're just thieves
you know those are the people that get
right because then they're like no it's
not true
you know it's like no it's true and
here's a million examples
you know those people get like you know
but
everyone comes out better everyone's
always
better more connected you're going to
get exactly what you need
especially in the right setting in the
right in the right with someone who
knows what they're doing
do you do these ceremonies in america
yes and then
how do you get the ayahuasca to america
or is that an
illegal question asked i mean no so
because it is an illegal substance right
no actually ayahuasca is legal the thing
is there's no dmt dmt is illegal
and the dmt is in the chakra
yeah and which is added how do you get
that
well so the thing is is that um
i have an organization that that was you
know is headquartered in costa rica
registered in five other countries being
the united states and so
when we're dealing with like the matrix
we're dealing with like we're dealing
with law and legalities right so the
the the case law regarding medicinal
you know the using of drugs as medicinal
or religious purposes has already been
argued
2006 supreme court case with this guy
james mooney from the udv
native american church with peyote
marijuana and then there's 2008
precedents for ayahuasca and supreme
court and in 2010.
so all the precedents and the statutory
laws put in place
on the supreme court down to the state
supreme court level regarding usage of
ayahuasca
so i think that ayahuasca should stay
exactly the way it is
i think that um if you're selling
ayahuasca to people
you you're you should be prosecuted
there's a big difference between
distributing a banned substance
and someone sending a donation into an
organization for a seat in a ceremony
you know if i if you come to the
ceremony and you drink two and a half
cups
then i'm then the pr then i don't charge
you 150
per cup that's distributing a banned
substance that's illegal you're paying
for a ceremony that happens to have
you're sending a donation into an
organization
right for a seat in a ceremony which is
up to 20 people
at which the the con the the
sacrament is ayahuasca yes whether you
drink a half a cup
two cups one cup irrelevant yeah that's
that's how we
we operate gotcha that's that's the
legal way for any religious organization
to distribute wine to a minor
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah okay now
so in other words you are getting the
actual ayahuasca and the trikuna from
the rainforest you're not like 100 yeah
i've made so fresh
i serve more i serve hundreds of like
i i serve a lot of ayahuasca yeah okay
and so
um so it's always being made and it's
always being sent to wherever i'm going
i have a whole organization i don't even
it's just all taken care of yeah
i basically like just deal with myself i
love it i serve medicine
yes you know what i mean it gets there
it's gonna be there
i just make sure i'm there you're right
right and everything is going to be
taken care of you know
thank you so much i don't want to take
up any more of your time alex has a
question
oh uh alex is curious about your opinion
on dr
sebi are you familiar with dr sebi the
vegan
guy yeah yeah he's no longer with us
yeah just heavy he had the revolution
regarding
um what's my opinion i mean i think he
i think that anything that becomes too
indoctrinated like there's no one
solution right
so so for example like humans are humans
right but if you go one step down the
human is the animal where with the soul
within right but
if you look at this the animal of man
there's many kinds of man right
so whereas like no one should be eating
red meat only
but at the same time not every person
will benefit from never having that in
their system
some humans might be able to digest it
better than others there isn't one way
yeah and so like the religion like
veganism for example has become a
religion
you know like the new virtue signal is
like i'm a vegan so they have like vegan
friends like
half my friends like we're gonna go to
like you why go to a steakhouse and then
[ __ ] that they don't have good vegan
options yeah you don't see steak
eaters going to the vegan place and
bitching is disrespectful you know
yeah so it's like i made this post one
time i said
um uh hitler was a vegetarian and jesus
ate meat
your diet doesn't define your
spirituality right and people went crazy
like how dare you compare
hitler and jesus i'm like how dare
compare the eating habits of two
well-known historical figures
yeah yeah so i think dr sebi was amazing
from the perspective of
he really embodied one aspect but i look
at
the whole thing of taking care of the
human body and or the spirit
as like hinduism like they have many
gods and goddesses and you may be drawn
to one thing you may be a devotion of
krishna
but that doesn't mean that the other
paths don't exist you know like when
after my first ayahuasca ceremony i
didn't eat
any meat or any animal product for like
two and a half years i went from like
to like 165 right well yeah i'm like 202
right now right
then i went and visited a friend he has
like this farm he's like
has like this most amazing lamb i was
like lamb i'm like afghanistan like lamb
dna is like dna is like you know they're
in the dna
activate yeah and i ate that and i took
the first bite
and i felt my body just come alive like
saying thank god
right and i after i ate i felt like
completely rejuvenated
so i feel the goal with anything is to
find your path like
i do green juice and celery juice like
three days a week
preparing for ceremony but on monday i
may order
lamb if my body says yeah for the most
part i stay vegan
but i if but i know what i need that's
the key yeah
not ask someone what i need you know i
think going in
you mean what i think of him as a person
or his system philosophy
yeah i think it's his fault yeah i think
his philosophy is
is important uh to exist on the earth
just as like a
as like a buddha or any of these you
know like
we needed an osho we needed all these
different
pers personas to come and that embody
one specific thing for us to see
as a guiding light and maybe we go down
that path for a month
maybe you go down that path for five
years right but the point is
you'll be you'll have another tool in
the in the surgery of life
to be able to implement with precision
you know
but i would never just like this is the
only way it's it's absolutely not true
there's no
you know there's there's no way but i
think but but him as a person like
let's look at him like you know he's a
living buddha
you